hey Joe you know I'm a good rapper right
yeah thanks
hey y'all I'm a good rapper right yeah
do you tell people like about that
you're a good reference yeah yeah yeah
you're a falafel or ever well what do
you say to people like you talk about
how a good rapper to people I tell
people you know I've heard a lot of
people rap at their time yeah but no one
should really rap like off the top of
their head like right like me right
yeah [ __ ] right off the top of my head
that's a good thing about me right
like I've never seen you write down
earrings no I don't you say I don't
write any lyrics I've never seen you
write that way but that's what I'm
saying that's why that's very good yeah
that's what school did you tell me what
I'm gonna be a rapper I have told
several people that you yeah you rap yes
good jokes like you know like you want
me to do it will never own bananas okay
yo yo it's like this like this yo yo
it's like this and that and this and
that
you got a banana man and I'm Chris and
now this is Joe court he's my friend and
I know well don't forget out cuz I'm
trying to do it you know you like to say
what you know you know it's like this
and that and this and that I get a
banana my name is Chris and when you're
doing
that's stupid I'm just saying like let
me do the wrapping and then what you do
you do your own [ __ ] after me like I
will you'd be like yo you ready for
Chris D'Elia do that but then I'm not
really doing there yeah with the two
tails up we're not running on me like
that's all I'm saying yeah that's all
I'm saying
but you say you tell people I'm a good
rap to them so they're yeah what do they
say when you said they didn't who said
they heard me who said they heard me
this one is like we're at Sonic on the
rubber man already a party man